hey guys it is Thursday January the 22nd
today my name is Jess McDonald and
you're watching gamespot you so Windows
10 event showed us a whole bunch of
things one of which was Xbox exclusive
fable legends coming to PC that
Microsoft Studios says that's just the
beginning xbox boss Phil Spencer stated
that the cooperative role playing game
by Lionhead Studios won't be the only
Microsoft Studios title to make its way
to Windows 10 Spencer has adjusted that
they intend to bring more of their
franchises to the platform in the coming
months the game development division of
Microsoft Studios is chrome to quite a
few internal studios will have heard of
including rare turn 10 who makes sports
halo developer 343 industries Gears of
War developer black tusk studios and of
course merging developer of Minecraft
above developer turtle rock studios are
having a hell of a time trying to
convince gamers that their use of DLC
isn't a bad thing after comments from
Turtle Rock Studios co-founder Chris
Ashton where he suggested that evolve
would support DLC quote more so than any
game ever before people were a tad
displeased gamers have been burned by
DLC and paid content a lot in the past
and evolved creative director Phil
robbers stepped in to say they aren't
trying to pull a fast one on you he told
destructoid we have the game set up in
such a way that we can expand upon it if
that is the desire our plan is one we
pushed for as consumers never split the
community note Peter win or that kind of
[ __ ] that are hallmarks of deal see
plans specifically made to leech money
out of people evolve presents a DLC
model where you'll get every map and
mode for free that total rock will sell
extra characters such as the behemoth
monster as well as other content packs
down the road we know Microsoft is
bringing xbox one to pc game streaming
by then you lean out streaming service
but apparently they're also planning to
do it at full 1080p at 60 frames per
second Microsoft's my cubero said that
although
so this is currently running at 720p and
30 frames per second they expect this to
improve to full HD by the time of its
official launch Gabara has noted that
maximum graphical output will be
dependent on the bandwidth speeds in
your home explaining it will really
largely depend on the scenario to which
someone is trying to play but we want to
make sure that we can get the optimal
experience hopefully this also means
we'll see more xbox one games running at
1080p and 60 frames per second soon let
me know down in the comments which
Microsoft franchise you'd most like to
see make its way over to PC you can add
the game shop for more stories on things
like the final resident evil movie king
of production and a trailer for the new
jet rising movie those are all the good
things that I wanted to tell you about
today tomorrow I'll have the five best
stories of the whole gaming week are all
ready to go so be sure to check back
then